all over the uk the enormity of what's
happening is sometimes
hard to absorb the health service
is overloaded to near breaking point
many hospitals have no more room left
for the dead
vast temporary mortuaries have been set
up and now there's a landmark figure
100 000 dead no one in our worst
nightmares
anticipated that would be here 10 months
into the pandemic with such a high
loss of life this is bradford
there are high levels of deprivation
poor housing
and ethnic minorities living close
together here
kovids has struck these communities hard
and this muslim cemetery is where many
of the dead are buried
the grave digging is relentless and
they're running out of space
kovid has frozen painful moments like
this
in the minds and hearts of too many
people
brothers fathers mothers daughters sons
taken by the virus and the numbers
increase remorselessly one
hundred thousand lives lost and how many
more to come
the scale of this ongoing disaster
can be measured in so many tragic ways
the crowded graveyards and the challenge
of
trying to visualize how many
lives have been lost as the counting of
those who've died continues a look at
the uk's biggest football stadium
wembley
can help convert those statistics into
some
sort of scale imagine every seat here
as one lost life and even with the
stadium
full it would fall ten thousand short of
the total
just as hard to visualize is the number
of those in mourning
charities that arrange counselling
estimate the number of bereaved at more
than half a million
we're worried that that's a silent
crisis going on behind
closed doors marie curie an end of life
charity says lockdowns mean many of the
bereaved
aren't getting help those people are
isolated
they're dealing with complex difficult
bereavement
and that they might not be getting the
support they need
shirley woods gallagher's father died
alone
she's shielding because of a health
condition and couldn't go to the funeral
instead she was given protective
clothing and allowed just a few minutes
beside her father's body
the rituals we have around funerals
wakes
building new lives scattering ashes um
are all taken from us with nothing put
in place
so i think the compassion around the
hundred thousand
um needs to be there in bradford
darkness doesn't stop the burials the
global spread of covid carries with it
a second pandemic mass grief